what's up my dudes i got a king
or sing it for you double hitter
and now it's not this mustache first off
being furry wow oh damn what do you
think keep it or shave it let me know
second of all y'all carry a knife
brandon you never know when you're gonna
need to cut some cake
i also never know when you're gonna need
to stab someone
video anyhow let me know boys gang gang
buzz buzz
buzz you really only see the hair on the
shoulder like that from
russian and armenian man okay it's very
rare you see it from
bernie getting racial out here you know
this european
[ __ ]
can't even deal with this [ __ ]
don't get racial in this guy this guy
obviously okay
shot steroids directly into his arms
because that's the only way does that
make you that hairy oh yeah
i don't know you're the one dude i could
grow a full back of hair right now
damn dude i'll grow you i'll grow each
one of you [ __ ] a sideburn
i appreciate that i can't throw hair for
[ __ ] you can't no i can't get no
chest hair no leg hair no arm hair
nothing yeah
hairless cat everybody just jumped out
of you you might have backflipped right
out of your hair man
probably something i did something wrong
something went wrong do you want body
hair
i mean i don't i don't know you don't
want it on your back i don't want to
know
he's got a weird patch that's springing
up i don't know where nick looks like he
has that duck tail hanging out the back
you got that duck they got that hairy
ass i bet
that patch oh my gosh oh that lat hair
oh yeah that's cancer baby
that is a early warning sign dude that's
that wisconsin patch of hair there
it's the only way cancer can let you
know something's like hey why don't we
try and send a signal let's send hair
out of a part of the body that has no
hair coming out of it
people are like hey look at this new
beard i got
look at this spine look at this goatee
on my lap yeah
now chin you're you're you're pretty
much hairless yeah
arms legs everything asians are hairless
yeah
yeah cat you're hairless of course yeah
i'm pretty hairless
half my team is hairless dude
[ __ ] team
dog i'm sick of your team i'm gonna i'm
gonna go [ __ ] your teammates bro
i'm a little jealous man dude most of my
teammates are men
why are you gonna go [ __ ] them
you trying to replace me with this
chinese softball team no i'm just
telling you our league is freaking legit
you fat
[ __ ] cake boy okay all right doug
how did the chinese feel about your nose
man huh how did you know about that nose
dude they'll get it gonna come in here
with that nose and act like everything's
all good
so i'm over at first two chinese dudes
will jump into my nose and i'll [ __ ]
score three runs for us
okay yeah your nose looks like you smell
a fart coming next week
[Laughter]
i will say this it's going to be colder
next week
i see how you see that joke on stage
like uh
that you could smell things that other
people couldn't smell it's gonna be
colder next week
he talked about knives too man i
probably shouldn't have this but
that's a reeves blade man and there's a
fella from louisiana makes a knife
called knox knives no x and i keep
having a
i've been planning a message in the back
for about a year and a half
i carry a knife when i ride bikes in
case one of the [ __ ] mountain
lions come out just
shank that [ __ ] she's like it's prison
for a mountain lion ain't attacking your
gay ass
yeah do you think he looks like i look
sweet
no dude i'm not lying you think he's
gonna drag you back and his other lion
buddies are like where you get that
little freaking
uh hill twink huh
who brought the [ __ ] i'm gonna feed the
whole tribe dog who brought the nerd
rope back here huh
go get us some real candy out there they
come back with this freaking bedazzled
thick boy dude that's dude who's knee
pads
and he's mountain biking like knee pads
bro
look at those there's like kind of
software team is this
are the coaches two gay ants what the
[ __ ] is this
what are you talking about jersey
traditional [ __ ]
mexi asian asian ware yeah no don't get
don't get chicken into it yes dude asian
likes asian like a lot of colors
isn't this traditional chinese where or
asian where i don't think so like this
you're
lying one of y'all's moms doesn't
[ __ ] have this no liars that's that
chocolate i will say my grandmother yeah
grandma something like grandma's
grandma's your dog
you said mom bro well that's fine older
mom
older mom this [ __ ] is fire boy
when you step on the field we [ __ ] you
up white boy yeah
i'm a little jealous of it i'll [ __ ] you
up with chinese we japanese we [ __ ]
syrian boy we [ __ ] you up
dude i'ma come down there and [ __ ] your
team up bro come out here boy
you want some of this [ __ ] [ __ ] white
boy you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
yeah me and my boys will be out there
you always sound mexican now [ __ ] you
homes i'm chinese
okay papa
yup i'll be stealing bases too
[Music]
is